شكرا لك جلال اهلا بك وبالمشاهدين الى هذه
النافذه مباشره من هنا من فندق بايرشر هوف
الذي يجتمع بداخله الوزراء والرؤساء وقاده
العالم
والخبراء الامنيون والدفاعيون وعلى
الطاوله طبعا موضوع اوكرانيا كاولويه
وموضوع دعم اوكرانيا سياسيا وعسكريا وايضا
مواضيع الطاقه وموضوعه المناخ لا يقل ايضا
اهتماما عن هذه المواضيع التغير المناخي
ولهذا ينضم الينا هنا في هذه النافذه
السيد جون كيري المبعوث الامريكي الخاص
لشؤون المناخ اهلا وسهلا بكري
سيد جون كيري طبعا مواضيع سياسيه وهميه
مطروحه هنا في هذا الفندق في هذه
الاجتماعات ولكن ايضا موضوع المناخ
والتغير التصدي للتغير المناخي
انخراط دول مثل الصين مثل روسيا وهي الدول
التي تتهمونها بانها السبب ايضا في التغير
المناخي كيف
تحافظون على التوازن او تشركونها في عمليه
التصدي التغير المناخي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا
الجميع هو خلف هذه الجهود العالم ككل لابد
ان يلحق بالجهود المبذوله ولدينا اجتماع
مهم سيجري في دبي الامارات العربيه
المتحده ستستضيف الاجتماع القادم لكل
الدول المشاركه فيما يخص موضوع المناخ
المساله الاولى التي لابد ان نقوم بها هي
كالتالي اولا النفي بالمتطلبات التي
وضعناها في باريس وفي جلاس جو هذا يعني
انه سيكون هناك تقييم عالمي لما وصلنا
اليه حتى الان مما سيزيد من مستوى
المسائله بالاضافه الى ذلك لدينا تقرير
التكيف الذي سيتم اعطاؤه لكل الوفود
المشاركه مما سيتطلب منا المزيد والمزيد
من الجهود فيما يخص هذا الجانب لدينا كذلك
ما يسمى بصندوق الاضرار والخسائر بالاضافه
الى ذلك لابد ان نزيد من مستوى خف
انبعاثات على المستوى العالمي لمده مسرع
من وتيره هذا الجرن هذا يتطلب منا اموال
حتى نتمكن من مساعده العالم النامي ليتخذ
الخطوات المطلوبه لنتجنب الاخطاء التي
ارتكبت تاريخيا ونحتاج الى طاقه نظيفه
لننتقل باتجاه الطاقات المتجدده والبديله
حتى نقوم باحتجاز الكربون وتخزينه الكربون
الذي ياتي من الوقود الاحفوري بما في ذلك
المنشات الهيدروجين وكذلك النوويه بطاريات
جديده وكذلك عمليه احتجاز وتخزين مباشره
وهذا ما سنحتاج ان نقوم به
نعم ولكن عندما تتحدث عن الطاقه البديله
والطاقه النظيفه والطاقه المتجدده هذا
يفترض ان تكون هناك علاقه مع الصين لان
الصين هي مصدر اساسي من مصادر هذه الطاقه
كيف يمكن بناء علاقه مع الصين للتعاون في
ظل الخلافات السياسيه الحاليه
لقد عملت وبشكل دؤوب في السنتين الماضيتين
بشكل خاص
مبعوث الرئاسي بشان المناخ لجلب الصين
للجلوس الى الطويل لتتعاون الصين معنى
لنجد سبيلا اننا جميعنا في هذه المركب هذه
القضيه ليست قضيه سياسيه بين الولايات
المتحده والصين هذه ليست قضيه استراتيجيه
او منافسه في هذا الاطار هذا الامر هو
منوط بنا كصين وكالولايات المتحده لان نحن
نعتبر اكبر دولتين من حيث الانبعاثات
غازات الدفينه وبالتالي لابد ان نعمل مع
بعضنا البعض ولدي اما الكبير انه في
الايام القليله والاسابيع القليله القادمه
سنتمكن ان نجتمع وكذلك نواصل النقاشات
التي بداناها في شرم الشيخ ونبدا في العمل
على ما اتفقنا عليه في السنتين الماضيه
نحتاج للصين وروسيا والهند والامارات
العربيه عفوا والاتحاد الاوروبي ودول اخرى
الاقتصادات الكبيره كلها لابد ان تكون في
اعلى الطاوله
نعم السؤال الهامي شو هنا بالنسبه لي
الصين الا يعني يعكر الموضوع او يعقده
موضوع المنطاد الصيني كيف يتطور الموقف
الامريكي او رده فعل الامريكيه من موضوع
الممتاز الصيني
اذا من الواضح ان
اعتراض الولايات المتحده بشان المنطاد
وكان هناك رده فعل من قبل الرئيس وكان
الرئيس محقا في ذلك لابد ان تخطى النظر
الى قضيه المنطاد لابد ان نتعامل مع بدر
البعض ولا بد ان نتجنب هذا النوع من
النزاعات لان هذا يقف عائقا امام قدرتنا
في مواجهه القضايا المهمه بالنسبه للشعوب
في الولايات المتحده في الصين وفي مناطق
مختلفه من العالم لابد ان نعمل على قضايا
تتعلق بالطاقه التي تعتبر امرا مهما عندما
يتعلق بكيفيه التعامل مع هذه الازمه لابد
ان نتعامل مع الطاقات النظيفه
والبديل بطريقه ذكيه الدول لابد ان تدخل
في مرحله انتقاليه للدخول في مجال استخدام
الطاقات النظيفه والمتجدده كل الدول
بامكانها ان تشاهد ان تشاء تتابع وتعمل من
خلال هذه التكنولوجيه الجديده هذه
الاموريه تعتبر استثمار وليست كلفه
وبالتالي هذا سيؤدي الى كوكب ارض اكثر
امانا بالنسبه لنا جميعا نحتاج الى الجميع
نحتاج الى كل دوله على حدى لتدفع بهذا
الاتجاه
قبل قليل عن كوب 28 في الامارات كان قبلها
في شرم الشيخ وتحدث ايضا عن اتفاقيه باريس
لكن هنا تحديدا
المصداقيه الامريكيه عندما تقرر امريكا ان
تخرج من اتفاقيات المناخ ثم تعود الى
اتفاقيه المناخ كما حدث في عهد ما الضامن
الا يحدث ذلك مستقبلا وتعود امريكا ربما
للخروج كما حدث في ايام ترامب
اذا كان هذا القرار تم اتخاده من قبل رئيس
خسر
الرئاسه ولن يكون هناك رئيس في السلطه
سيفعل ذلك لماذا لان رؤساء الشركات الكبرى
المؤسسات ورؤساؤها التنفيذيون كلهم كلهم
اعتمدوا وتبنوا هذه المرحله الانتقاليه
يعلمون انهم لابد ان يمضوا قدما في هذا
الاتجاه جوجل ابل مايكروسوفت وسيس فورس
كلها كلها شركات كبيره وكثيره تبذل قصار
جهدها من اجل خفض بعثاتها من اجل
المساهمه في خفض البعثات ليس هناك امكانيه
لرئيس ليفعل ذلك لان هناك اموال كبيره تم
استثمارها في هذه المرحله الانتقاليه هم
فعلا فعلا يعتمدون على هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه وبالتالي هناك مركبات كهربائيه
تم انتاجها وبدات الكثير من الشركات
بالمضي قدما في هذا الاتجاه هذا الامر
الذي يتغير هذا الامر لن يحدث
باوكرانيا ويعني هؤلاء المجتمعون الان في
هذا الفندق كانوا هنا العام الماضي وربما
ثلاث اربعه ايام بعد اجتماعهم دخل او غزا
بوتين اوكرانيا الان منذ السنه وروسيا في
اوكرانيا بوتين مصر على لم ينهزم بعد ما
زال موجودا لم ينسحب بعد سنه من
غزوه لاوكرانيا كيف تقرا بين قوسين هذا
الصمود الروسي في اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان الرئيس بوتين ارتكب خطا فظيعا
بتداعيات
وحسابات كبيره لم يقم بحساب العمليه
بطريقه صحيحه لقد اظهر الشعب الاوكراني
شجاعه كبيره لديهم رؤيه لبلدهم لن
يتنازلوا هكذا فجاه
اعتقد ان غزو روسيا غير قانوني هو ضد كل
القوانين الدوليه وهو يسحب الجميع الى
الخلف الى القرن الماضي الى اخر مره تم
فيها غزو بلد كان ذلك في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ولقد عملنا جميعنا من اجل علم
افضل بالنسبه لشعوبنا وبالنسبه لكوكب
الارض لدينا قوانين دوليه معاهدات ومعايير
للسلوكيات لا تقتل السجناء وهم مقيدي
الايدي هذا غير مسموح بحسب قوانين الحرب
الامميه المعايير التي وضعناها معامله
المراه والاطفال الحالات الاغتصاب والقتل
هذه جرائم حرب ما نقوم به هنا هو ان نقف
من اجل الحريه من اجل سياده القانون من
اجل التعامل بطريقه تحترم الاخرين من اجل
القوانين والمعايير التي عمل عليها العالم
منذ الحرب العالميه
ونشعر اننا داعمون وبقوه عندما نفكر هؤلاء
الناس عندما يتوقفون سيفهمون ليس هناك اي
نازيين في اوكرانيا الامر لا يتعلق بهذا
الجانب الامر يتعلق بسحب اراد يتم السيطره
عليها من قبل دوله واحده وهذا القائد قائد
وحيد هو الذي اتخذ هذه القرارات هذه تعتبر
ماساه انا اعرف الرئيس بوتين عملت معه
عندما كنت وزير خارجيه امريكيه وعملنا
وقمنا باشياء كثيره فعلا اسف اسف الى هذا
التحول في الاتجاه لان يعتبر هدري للحياه
للارواح للموارد ويعتبر فعلا فعلا لحظه
سيئه والتاريخ له ان يحكم ما حدث في هذا
الاطار
بما انك تعرف تماما
بوتين فلاديمير بوتين وعملت معه عندما كنت
وزيرا للخارجيه الامريكيه
الرجل الذي يمكن ان يستسلم ان ينسحب في
النهايه هل يمكن ان تنتهي هذه الحرب
بانتصار اوكرانيا على روسيا مثلا
ونعود الان الى جلال في الاستوديو اليك
جلال